[Applause]
hello oh i need your help mate
what do you need life a luxury uploaded
in another video oh god another one uh
two years ago
have you seen this one ken
i have not
for the first time i've actually not
seen this one yet
what do you mean you've seen the other
videos we've reacted together already
no
of course not okay good all right good
last one was really funny i look forward
to see the doo-woo yeah the boys back in
time they got the ladies they got the
haircuts going on they got the hair
short yeah oh man he really looks like
ruby come
on come by
with chester he's ready chester
dude this is crazy i can't believe bro
it's chester and parker i remember their
names
wow
all right we gotta get a preview what's
to come making those sounds right dude
what kind of tv shows
whatever they say dude
instant dopamine hit i love it
do you think the voices could be in your
head maybe because you miss your family
yeah
nice can't wait
i can see it all
every little detail
your browsing the internet without a vpn
don't worry
i got you
nordvpn.com
pewdiepie hooking you up with secure
internet
safe safe behind a wall
of next-gen encryption double protection
change your ip twice to cover your web
traffic
double protection but what if they look
at my stuff no vpn still no they don't
strict no logs policy another explosion
they don't track anything don't worry
your secrets
no one can reach them
they have vpn servers all over the world
baby 59 countries are there even that
many countries
no one knows
access the world worldwide as it's meant
to be the world wide web not some
worldwide behind the wall because you're
in this country
no and nordvpn helps you get past all
that jumbo mumbo's mumbo browse the
internet freely and securely you can use
it on your phone you can use it on your
other devices and it's easy you just do
this click done bingo bingo you can say
bingo while you click it it feels good
trust try it bingo
do it a little
if you don't use no vpn he will kill me
that's true i've talked to the nordvpn
people and
they will kidnap my dog
why is that so funny
if they approve it i'll be happy
they have over 5400 servers that's a lot
of servers
you don't even know what server is but
yet your life depends on it that's
interesting how that works and of course
you know i won't let you guys go without
an epic deal huge discount on a two-year
plan and my [ __ ] will be safe
plus
four additional months for free discount
free use the link in description to get
access for it nordvpn.com pewdiepie
you're welcome let's go on with the
video can't
wait this is gonna be a scary one i can
tell i'm already scared man i'm so
scared i spilled something on my shirt i
got a stain
you're eating while we're watching
yeah yeah
of course i i stress eat man
can't help it it's too scary
got it
hello lux army before we start this yeah
lux army yeah
people called me out they were like but
pewdiepie you call it bro army i never
called the bro army okay everyone else
did did you not call it bro i never
called it bro army
everyone else did yes really i made a
point even to tell to my stupid network
at the time because they kept going oh
yeah the bro army we need to sell them
this t-shirt i'm like no bro army it's
weird
and they just people kept doing i'm like
all right fine bro bro army broadway
nation whatever you want
huh
it wasn't me well the lore is very
interesting i didn't know that i thought
i thought you did the whole bro army
thing
no
always a speaker against but sometimes
bro but you know bro army just too
strong
you don't have a name for your channel
like audience do you my community no i
don't i kind of feel like i've really
missed the ball on making my cult i mean
because i cause i call them cinnamon
toasters last video about cinnamon
toasters yeah and i saw someone had a
problem with that i don't remember what
they said just as bad as the people who
are in the comments and i'm like hey you
know what should i what should i call
you guys and everybody's
like so maybe name is like cinnamon
toast kids or something or toast or
cinnamon
and i'm just like
can we think of anything that isn't just
my name with like a different word on
the end
now
where's the creative juices give me some
creativity okay i got it cinnamon army
i like how bts just cut cut through all
the like army
[Laughter]
just army there's army
this video let's try to smash that like
button and get the most likes all right
let me smash it 75 why can't i just
click on the like button do i have to
smash it how do you smash it this must
been way back in the days they only
wanted 75 000 likes not a hundred less
all right guys
gently as gently as possible click on
the like button of this video
touch it like you would touch
the cheeks of your favorite
person
like that bts army
dude we pissed off no one in that video
i know great hey but if this video gets
200 000 likes i'll poop in the shower
how about that
for real for real you'll do that for me
come on you can't say that and not do it
i mean we'll have to see if we get the
likes or not you know if we get the
likes i'll think i'll look into it you
know probably take for you to poop in
the shower king for me to poop in the
shower
come up bro i'm gonna need something to
poop in the shower you know i want this
video to get a ton of likes but your boy
oh cindy winnie over here is gonna have
to get something
five million subs up poop in the shower
how about that oh
wait don't you have that already no i
don't
okay four million i'm crying with some
baby over here jesus christ it's like
this baby channel oh god thanks for the
charity man you don't even have to dive
and play fun mr b's got that in a week
bro come on
[Laughter]
listen this this hurts me leave me alone
all right sorry so for this episode we
received a report from a 19 year old
girl named emma who's been here 19 year
olds
in her house she says that when she's
alone at night in her room she hears
voices outside of her door what does he
do with his
hands it's giving a really bad ted talk
he's like he's moving something from the
left right he's like look shake it over
here shake it up with it
the italian one so he's he's just very
maybe he's happy italian maybe that's it
he also has his grin on his face like
yeah well named emma who's been hearing
strange voices in her house she says
that when she's alone at night in her
room she hears voices outside of her
door pretending to be her mom and other
family members she sent us this video
for proof
so tonight oh it sounds like your mom
just want to go in there yeah that's it
rude
there's a short story of a
someone calling someone from downstairs
like your mom's calling me from
downstairs and i'm like hey come down
here and help me uh classic car yeah and
then they're behind you come out and
like yeah mom like opens the other doors
like that's not me you're like oh god
but who is it then but who is it wait
who is the real one is it you and the
cause
why is that so creepy that concept
because it gets your imagination going
you're like oh yeah and we played a lot
of horror games and we yeah we know a
lot about horror
and your own imagination is definitely
the the most powerful thing
it's not the jump scare screw five
nights at freddy's no you know what
you're giving people too much credit
their imagination sucks i don't believe
this
anyway
we're gonna head out to emma's house and
see what's going on but first a quick
word from our sponsor right shadow
legends
so do you think there's actually someone
doing these voices in this girl's house
i mean it seems like it did you see the
video she sent us it could have been
like the tv making those sounds right
dude what kind of tv show sounds like
that i don't know dude i'm just sketched
out by this right now it could have been
the tv outside her door happens all the
time the tv
dude there's this movie on like bro like
netflix that's like i think it's called
like killer couch or something like that
a killer recliner they get this like
reclining chair and it like
moves around and tries to get people but
it's got like this weird looking face on
it yeah dude
yeah dude that's crazy this could the
same thing could happen to the tv to
where the tv is coming over there
just allergic to the acting
um sneeze and also just notice how this
girl's like got her dress on in the
middle of the night i guess she's going
to party i don't know
oh such girls aren't allowed to have
dresses on at night i mean would you
dress like this if you thought you
creepy dead mom or whatever was
happening outside
parker is coming to my house boy you
better know i'm putting on the best
thing i got hey i'll take it back
what's up boys
okay thank you
put some grease on that door please
wd-40
yeah
it takes i want to go there right now
tonight here what the [ __ ] look at that
you're telling me every time you open
that door they make that sound and
you're not doing anything about it
that's worse than any ghost could be
more of a death than me right now
well i gotta grease my ballet songs all
the time you know what i'm saying
this couch is in the corner of the room
this is so weird what is wrong with
people we need like interior design
courses in school what do you do just
put a cell phone sit on the couch and
watch them come in your door
oh god and pillows himself the stuff is
already i don't think it's appeals to
myself emma can you tell us and what's
with that creepy artwork over there
oh my god
and glass
tables you stainless
a little bit salmon on that you're done
you gotta wipe the whole thing there
at the same time
so at night i hear voices what do these
voices say to you so usually it's just
this one voice and it says
emma it's mom come out of your room
so you hear your mom's voice it sounds
like my mom but i haven't i haven't
lived with my mom in four years
oh that's creepy oh man that's creepy
that's actually creepy it works the
concept works oh my god what would you
do
what would you do kenneth happened to
you if i was back in america what i
would do is when i hear the voice when
there's something my door i'll just be
like blah blah blah and then kick it
open real quick and be like alright
what's up
you know i'll be ready to go but now
that i'm in australia i'd have to like
you know
kick open the door and throw my
crocodile at
them sounds like a shitty like video
game
weapon you know the weird ones you get
you get a crocodile and a stick or
something
yeah
but for real though what if what i would
really do what i imagine i would do yeah
is is get ready to fight for my life and
open the door and just kind of jump out
and like get them before they get me
kind of thing that's what i think i
would do you know what i would do
hey bro
you flipping your knife at me right now
you think you're bad
[Music]
well you can stay in your room what you
want i don't you didn't have to let me
in i'm just playing whoa dude chill out
really if if i actually heard my mom
outside my door i'm like what a great
surprise
mom you came all the way
oh
i guess that's true i just said i'd open
the door to fight my mom what if it was
really hurt no
rest in peace mom she had to catch his
hands
i haven't asked you this have you seen
the kangaroo yet in australia it just
ran that you said crocodile you seen it
yeah yeah absolutely they're everywhere
they're all over the place man really
yeah
huh like you don't you don't see them in
the cities or anything of course but
when you go out of the city yeah they're
just all over there everywhere you
fought one yet no but i'm waiting i've
been waiting i've been training you know
yeah i made a box you see that as soon
as i take down the kangaroo you know i'm
going after i'm going after the paul
brothers
oh boxing got it okay nice they sound
like my dad and sometimes my grandma and
my grandpa they would only say things
that my family would know or they would
say they would only say things
that my grandma would know
or that my grandma would say
i am acting right now ken
can you hear it
wow i thought you was just that's so
good
thank you that was too sorry
not actually them right i think so but
sometimes it just gets it gets too
personal
so have you ever tried to see where
these voices are coming from not too
personal
have they established like why they're
calling these guys are they at some
point i think they're fans i think
they're supposed to be fans like oh i
need some help
okay
youtubers
because they saw the videos and how
helpful they are right yeah how you know
everyone always dies yeah exactly
they're right outside the door i can't
get up and just get to the door because
you're too scared to get up
it's too scary do you think the voices
could be in your head maybe because you
miss your family bro you she sent a
video chester don't gaslight this poor
woman she was the one behind the camera
probably going like open the door you
know whatever
yeah
all right i'ma listen i know you're
going through a really tough time right
now but we're going to help you i want
you to go to sleep normally tonight and
act normal we're going to set up cameras
from your house and we're going to watch
a live stream of the kids oh live stream
this time
we're going to try to do live
bro i am so glad that chester learned
how to use like the odd the the
anti-shake whatever the option is on
your camera because when he's looking at
his boy parker over here it's like he's
got parkinson's you know he's shaking it
i feel bad
you got parkinson's i apologize you know
but his name is parker so it's funny
that's the joke yes
they love putting it on the blinds you
put on the blondes thanks
beginner wait
[Music]
okay so we're waiting in the car right
now it looks like amazon oh they're in
the car they're going to stay in a
bedroom in our house
nice i like that
all right yeah check it around
isn't there something creepy about just
like filming a girl sleeping
yes but they do it they usually do it to
people's moms
what is that on the right side of the
who puts a plant right there yeah it's a
terrible spot for a plant in every
conceivable way or
it's the monster
random tangent because it this pisses me
off so much when i click on x on a
[ __ ] program i expect it to close it
and when i click the minimize button i
expect it to be minimized
x does not mean minimize you dumb smug
program things oh you
you just wanted to cloak what the hell
is that why is that a thing
i don't know man why is the point of the
minimize button then i don't know
[Music]
at least on dangle the minimize button
in front of me and say that you have a
purpose
okay
at least remove that then and we can
pretend that they are sorry dude this is
crazy dude dude we're gonna be waiting
here all night
bro you don't have a choice
no choice no choice
actually got a leg hanging out from
under the covers a little bit
yeah yeah got to be cool was that
stefano back there
hell yeah
family there it is
dude wake up chester is sleeping totally
for real real bruh there you go just
lean back a little bit no it's all good
don't even lay the seat down how do you
sleep like that what just switch to
another one
okay that's good
he ate another camera was it a guy dude
yo quick
dude
we're gonna lose all our gopros if this
continues oh god save the gopros
turn up the audio see if we can hear
anything dude go with that let's call
the cops dude
see if you can hear something first
okay yeah yeah we need to stream audio
wirelessly on the gopro
no no i don't know can you maybe no you
can't no you can't can't maybe if you
get extinction
[Music]
don't do it
dude
my camera's glitching out now i think oh
oh god
oh no
oh god oh bro he could just oh what is
happening to my camera
okay it's fine he could just open the
door the whole time
he was like oh you didn't lock your door
tonight
i'm coming on in
is that filthy frank is that who that is
[Laughter]
oh it's in the corner
i'm fine guys i don't need your help
anymore where's emma
um
oh my god so cracking and broke in the
house
jesus
it is filthy frag
it's fine guys
[Laughter]
this one's great love this
so look she's [ __ ] smiling uh
so the monster took her dress and
switched t-shirts or like what happened
give her
hello
i love that
that's the whole plot you know you
notice the dress rubber dress wanted to
look pretty he just wanted to look
pretty
i gotta see some this is some dude
resting at the rest dude
he's very mad about it
[Applause]
oh this blurred the face is a dude in
the dress
is that chester
i haven't seen a wall i haven't seen
jester
mommy i know you did this slow down do
you know you can use the greater than
less than symbols to like go frame by
frame oh
no way oh sh oh my god i didn't know i
could do this you didn't know oh i dude
this is like i always do this thing oh
this is the best oh my god yeah you can
make them dance and everything
[Music]
wearing a dress come on now what's up
not so spoopy anymore
did they give did they give him lipstick
[Applause]
they actually saved them well done maybe
they used to save them back in the day
and then they became the demons at some
point now they're just
oh man there's a lot of this video left
i don't know how much longer she'll be
alive
whoa chester just dropped camera
hey guys thank you for watching this
that was it buck's army
yeah what is all this then what is this
then what is this all this
that's what they're taking a dump in
their bush what
is that
what the [ __ ] is all this a preview from
uh look at him
i'm glad they saved somebody you know
well they signed
uh a comment do you think the voices are
in your head or something oh so you can
hear her thoughts like a psychic
[Laughter]
nice oh people got scared of this one
this one actually was scarier than like
the last one was just
the audio on this one made me jump a
couple of times yeah like no and i was
like oh god okay
when they do that boom bra sound effect
gets me every time we watch the horror
on netflix and they use like those
generic like
sound effects i'm like are you [ __ ]
like
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like what the
[ __ ] am i watching dude you gotta get
that with some free free to use things
can be paying for licenses and stuff
please cool my camera's not working
nothing's working today it can
get a better camera
damn yeah my old one work fine it's fine
they can imagine my face
another amazing life of luxury videos
the boys did it again well done thank
you so much for having me that was a
beautiful beautiful one to share this
well check out live luxury check out ken
all hopefully one day five mil subs that
would be so cool i'm trying to get to 10
you know then i can call myself a real
boy but you know i'll i'll just keep
showing up
channel 100 million it's fine i can't
believe i've been collaborating with
this small fry this whole time oh my god
leave me alone
leave me alone i can't help but i'm
doing my best well you just gotta kill
people into subs can that's like we're
doing now no this is probably gonna work
out pretty well i mean sure the most
subs i ever got from you like from doing
a collab with you is when they thought
you deleted my system32 i got so many
they were like oh my god he really
deleted system32 no it was edited of
course he didn't freaking anyway thanks
for subbing
and sub to me not enough subscribers
very disappointed
need more asap if you later birthday
happy birthday stay tuned to my friends
i love you bye
you thought it was dead
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers are
emotions memes are emotions
express your emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time
circle baby download it make a meme
[Music]
we need subtitles on this